the biggest decision facing our new
prime minister is when to call a general
election with a likely majority of just
two or three including the flaky Ulster
Unionists and having made a whole range
of new enemies amongst these Tory
colleagues by sacking half the cabinet
Johnson has no option but to go to the
people to try to get a bigger majority
but it will be a risky strategy if he
holds the election before we leave the
EU the brexit party are likely to steal
a fair number of their votes meaning the
toys are unlikely to get a majority if
he waits until after we've left the EU
it might not happen at all Johnson's
only home could be to negotiate a brand
new deal with EU and then go to the
country but why would he you leaders
give him that they clearly don't like
him and they could do the mass just like
us the next few months are likely to be
very rocky and Boris Johnson's time as
PM could be one of the shortest in
history I think you're overlooking a big
factor which is that it is in the
interests of the EU just as it is in the
interests of the UK that we get some
sort of deal across the line so I think
actually what would be quite fun is if
we will made our predictions as what's
going to happen for Celia results in the
envelope and open it maybe in six months
time and I probably who nothing we have
predicted would have happened because
there things are so unpredictable I
think that plan a is what he said on the
strictest steps of Downing Street which
is he will do his utmost to try and get
a deal through which I think he has a
chance of putting lipstick on the pig
and bringing home the bacon because if
they're in the danger he faces from as
you point out those 17 people he's
sacked plus the 40 or so who voted
against No Deal
is far greater than the danger he faces
from the brexit party or for the euro
skeptics in his on his own side so I
think there's going to be a huge will on
both sides of the channel for him to get
the deal through and if he does get the
deal through I think you're right he'll
have to go to the country he needs a
bigger majority he doesn't have a
majority in the Commons if he goes to
the
they haven't got a deal so wait yeah
absolutely
go straight country with having got no
deal he won't but I disagree problems I
used to I used to think that too but
I've just been thinking about the last
few days
if he starts campaigning in the next
couple of weeks right so he's
campaigning on on an honor on a brexit
the the campaign would be together said
of the EU that we have and a democratic
legitimacy and it would be led by a man
who's absolutely you know keen and keen
to do this and I ask does he do a deal
with Faraz before but he wouldn't have
to because if he's campaigning on greg's
did before the 31st he's got half a
child I didn't I didn't believe it but
the more I think about it it still he
won't have momentum so you think you
might call an election I've read it I
think it would be very wise of him to
call an election in the next 28 days
because what yes because holiday it
would be it's a risky strategy but he
neutralizes the brexit party because
he's campaigning for brexit not see that
country's not ready the nation would not
want his best chance well you you
interesting you talk about Nigel Faraj
in the brexit party let's see what mr.
Faraj has to say about this possibility
the Conservative Party historically find
it very difficult to work with any other
political party now there were some
saying look at the logic Donald Trump is
one of them you know some say look at
the Peter breh by elections where the
brexit party and conservatives between
them get more than 50% of the vote but
label in the seats with 31% of the vote
so there are some arguments out there
that say a PAC might work but at the
moment it's not easy to see to someone
so we get Rachel involved but that's
clearly the cabinet that he's put
together is also going to be a war
cabinet it's an election cabinet it's
absolutely life and soul of the
Conservative Party and Boris's message
if he to use your lovely expression if
he puts lipstick on the pig and brings
home the bacon or whatever it was and
then he goes to the poll and remember
he's got Dominic Cummings behind sort of
this mastermind this Svengali figure by
God I reckon he's got a hell of a chance
at underway he's already said that
withdrawal agreements dead so he can't
put lipstick on the pig he's got
together Dominic count how many
becoming hates for us and that that part
of the of the breaks accounting this
this he has a legitimacy problem I mean
it's already it's already a hung
parliament so the Conservatives had that
anyway but going forward this is a man
who is now Prime Minister because you
know ninety seven thousand people
seventy one percent of the male ninety
seven percent of them white voted for
him now I know that's the system that we
let me finish I know that's the system
that we're in but it does create a
legitimacy problem and it's but I have
to say it's very strange sitting here
listening to you all greet Boris Johnson
as Prime Minister in a sort of
gloriously like it's some kind of rise I
think I'm gonna just speak up for the
people who actually are very frightened
how does the lady finish Carol there are
people in this country the people who
are vulnerable will feel frightened by
this minority communities will feel
frightened by his election we're looking
at a man who is manifestly ill-equipped
reckless dangerous person and a lot of
people feel very uneasy in minorities in
London and I think that for a lot of
people in this country he does have a
legitimate legitimate problem let's get
back to the election I mean if you look
at the latest polls 31 percent find
Johnson favorable now may was a forty
eight percent when she became prime
minister and she still didn't get she
didn't get an election she's she shall
one and didn't lots of majority odds are
still that he won't cool won in 2019
according to the polls it's 64 okay well
if he gets the stage where he well I
don't know what happens is he gets to
the stage where he can't get a deal from
Brussels and I don't think he will
and therefore it's either we crash out
no and none of us know what happens then
it'll be 90 something we've got 90 was
definitely 90s whatever day you're
watching this we've got 90 something
dazed here we won't know where we are
for those 90 days that's what's driving
there was an election no party can be
confident of a majority because you know
we you know a year ago the two main
parties the Tories and labor they were
sharing we're like
no 80-something no no between each that
was 39% total of 78 or 79 percent that's
totally changed now they're 25
percentage the Lib Dems are at 18% and
and the greens are at 6 so that no party
is gonna get good it could be the only
time in in my lifetime when the
first-past-the-post system actually
works engaged the toys and the Labor
Party actually works in favor doing the
interesting thing will be whether you
know there is actually a vote of
no-confidence if he tries to run No Deal
through Parliament we actually and that
will be the test
are there enough conservative get it
through part are there enough
conservatives who are willing to support
a vote of no-confidence at that point
because they've had a few months to see
just how reckless and how damaging Boris
Johnson as Prime Minister really how can
you say it's gonna be reckless and
damaging hasn't done anything what he
did he set out his store the other day
and he said what it was gonna do let's
judge him on this he said he was like a
mixed social care he said he was gonna
fix school Theresa May said she was
going to be not doing that the next
thing you just words Carol any minute
now
we'll hear those 97,000 services didn't
know what they were well he'll have to
be negotiating well they'll see levander
line can I hear from hurt we want to
hear from her she how terrified that
she's just this reckless new premier
first of all congratulations to Boris
Johnson to be nominated as Prime
Minister and I'm looking forward to have
a good working relationship together
we have challenging times ahead of us I
think it is very important to build up a
strong and a good working relations with
people in Europe and in the United
Kingdom so I'm looking forward to
working with him I think as I said
desperation both sides to get some deal
through then we're going to see a Boris
pant and an economic bounce
yeah we're going to bounce on to other
things